well it's Wednesday time for our pet of
the week segment Mary Howard with
foreclosed upon pets is here great to
see you thank you for having us and
you've got to get a cute little puppy
dog here who is this this is Kai he is a
nine month old min pin male
uh he does have a little bit of a bum
leg there it he was born with it
it doesn't deter him in any way he runs
as fast as he can and he loves to play
he likes to chew he's just a sweet boy
it's just a little misshapen front left
leg Yeah you called it a chicken wing
yeah
but you said he's active and he just
absolutely just runs around everywhere
you have to be understanding of the fact
that he is a puppy and he likes to chew
he definitely likes to chew and he's
good with dogs but you don't know about
cats we don't know about cats and he's
really good with kids okay oh that's
great even you know younger ones so he
might be he'd be a good family pet yes
absolutely he's sweet how much bigger
will he get I don't think he's going to
get too much bigger okay what's his
adoption fee his adoption fee right now
is 300 okay because he is a puppy we
have to put extra shots and things into
them so it costs a little more well it's
spring and that's usually kitten and
puppy season what's going on with puppy
we got lots and lots and lots of animals
do you have of kittens right a lot of
kittens right now okay and uh do you
need Fosters Fosters we need volunteers
well we're going to try to get Kai a
good home here aren't you aren't we
sweetie yes we are oh you're social
Beauty yes you are
well if you're interested in adopting
Kai or fostering or volunteering with
puppy you can call the number right
there on your screen you can also email
them they have a Facebook page too and
if all else fails you can always go to
our website 8newsnow.com WE Post these
segments right there and you can find
all that information Kai is adorable
with his little chicken wing Mary says
he's a fast runner too so it doesn't
slow him down a bit you know humans can
learn so much from animals so you just
keep going through